what's up everybody welcome to part five
of the web development with Python and
Django tutorial series in this video
we're gonna be working a little bit on
design I'm no designer so we are
actually going to be using a CSS
framework because if you've ever had
ever tried to do CSS purely all on your
own there's so many things that you got
to do to get just a somewhat decent
looking website so what a CSS framework
does for you is kind of gives you a head
start so to speak or it pretty much can
do everything for you so the one that
we're going to use is called
materialized materialized CSS so I'll
just go ahead and click on that and this
is basically it uses what's referred to
as material design which is kind of
meant to certain things are like lifted
above things and it looks more like
pieces of paper almost or something like
that I'm sure some designers like that's
not what it is at all but anyway that's
kind of the way you I at least recognize
a material design if we go to like
images maybe yeah I mean it's just kind
of like the the feeling that certain
things are layered on top of things is
kind of the general concept regardless
like I said I'm not a designer let's get
to what what we care about so first of
all to use a CSS framework you're pretty
much just gonna do the same thing that
you would do if you made your own CSS
which is what we've actually already
kind of done together snippet so first
of all let me let me go ahead and pull
up I'm not even running the website oh
my gosh who is this teacher server and
then we'll just come over here great
hopefully it runs oh hopefully a hidden
error why did it not here we go okay I
guess it just started up slow anyway
like we did to get the CSS to work here
right and the JavaScript actually we had
to do both of those things and I thought
I was gonna have to reopen this and so I
was freaking out for
moment so if we go to like home here we
can see we loaded this the CSS so yeah
we can actually you can load many CSS I
always want to call him CSS sheets but
CSS literally stands for a cascading
style sheets so yeah you shouldn't call
it CSS sheets but I'm probably gonna do
it I apologize in advance anyway
if we want we can include another one so
let's just come on over and we'll use
both of these so I'm actually gonna grab
I think we'll go ahead and just grab
both of them for now and we just put
them at the top I don't actually know if
we can get away with putting the
JavaScript at the bottom in this case we
probably can't there's probably some
things in that JavaScript that are going
to be required to be initial feel free
to comment below if I'm wrong you can't
do put it in the bottom that's fine
anyway so let's refresh boom we should
see immediately really the only thing
that changed is our text we're clearly
using some other font than the default
but other than that it pretty much looks
the same but the thing is you can do a
whole lot of things with this so I'm
just going to show some quick examples
but also if we if we come to Python
programming Dannette you'll see this is
also material design this is
materialized CSS as well so it's the
exact same framework as I'm using here
all this stuff is material designed like
these cards giving the impression that
they're like on top that's material
design even the navbar acting like it
like is a layer on top that's material
design as opposed to like the difference
here like this footer I've many wouldn't
really call that material because it
doesn't look like the footers on top or
something but anyway that's all that
that really means but anyways I kind of
like the design I think it looks good so
getting a little dated this was new and
I I made Python programming on net I
actually have no clue what the current
in styling is but anyways so so we've
got basically the JavaScript and then
basically all from here or the CSS and
the JavaScript from here what I would
suggest is if you're using a framework
like this
click on all the things and then go
through all the things especially like
here color grid helpers grid is super
useful to have basically we'll talk
about this here in just a moment but
just understand a grid it thinks it has
12 columns per row so you can assign
things and then if you continue going
down here you can see like how would you
write the code to get like something
that takes up all the columns and then
something that's half and half and then
something that sits all the way over
here and then this is like not half and
half like something has five something
as seven and so on and you can do all
all the combinations you could possibly
think of using this sort of grid layout
so will you make use of that I'm trying
to think here nothing else really
obviously tables are pretty useful so
you might want to check that out but
then the next big thing is components
things like buttons footer nav bar we're
kind of interested we'd probably like to
have a nav bar pagination is sort of
nice you still got to make the code for
pagination so it could be kind of a pain
and then we'll pop over to JavaScript
see what else we have here
we've got collapsibles which is how I do
like the sidebars probably nothing else
I want to talk about besides toasts
which we'll hit on later to get pop-up
messages so the first thing I want us to
go ahead and do is talk about rows so
let's go into basically right here how
would we handle for these tutorials so
for two basically for tutorial and
tutorials we're iterating over those but
we might rather than like stacking them
on top of each other we might want to
like put them side to side kind of like
we do here right there these are so many
side to side but as I reef size this
window you can see that certain things
drop down or you know get moved over and
all that like that and so on so I may
not know what kind of device are viewing
on your viewing experience changes so
that's what we can use these rows for so
first of all we'll start off with div
class equals row and then we'll close
off the div tag whoops there we go again
not really going to talk too much about
like what are divs and what are all
these other things but it's just kind of
like a way the div tag is explaining the
type of content that's in between there
I guess I'll go with that for now
so then what we're gonna do is specify
so this is rose so for example what if
we so actually I'll move some stuff
around in a little bit I think we'll
start with that for now so if we said
div class row for tutorial in tutorials
in fact you know what I want to do I
kind of want to come over
I want to grab will go to components
cards yeah let's just like grab this
card so I'm actually gonna copy this
card
come over here I don't want to write it
all out and then we'll just cut this and
this will come down here awesome paste
come over here fix the alignment here
really okay I guess I'll do that okay so
really this would be row and then in
here is probably where you would want to
place your for tutorial loop so in here
we would say for tutorial Boop and then
end for at the end of this here have
this over will say that we'll come over
here obviously it's just gonna be like a
sample card right it's so it's just
tutorials by the way this works is this
says on a small screen take up all 12
columns on a medium screen take up 6 and
then you can also specify on a large L
for large take up for for example and
that way so you could get like three
things on a full screen 2 things on like
a tablet and then just one thing if
you're viewing it you know on a mobile
phone vertically so and probably
horizontally do anyways okay so we are
iterating over our tutorial card title
well we could just replace this with
tutorial title tutorial or actually it
would be two tutorial title then here we
would probably say
unfortunately we got way too much
content but that's okay
we'll get there a little later to talk
tutorial dot tutorial underscore content
we actually don't need a card action so
I'm just gonna delete that for now later
we actually might have a card action
like you know go so visit or something
like that
and then let me just throw in a couple
more and in fact let me just copy this
paste and then we're gonna say style
equals and we'll set this to like a font
size of 70% and then rather than content
let's call that published published save
that's come over here refresh beautiful
oh we forgot our safe safe tag and then
so you guys visit like a call to action
basically so let me add a tutorial
content safe flag I guess not really a
tag boom okay now we got our beautiful
snippet okay so we're doing pretty darn
well off to a good start the next thing
I'd like us to go ahead and do is work
on possibly adding a nav bar so let's
come over here and we'll go into nav bar
and I think probably I think we'll just
grab that first one just for example
there are tons and nav bars for us to
choose from okay I'm gonna go with this
one though so I'm just literally copy
come over here under body paste in
general
basically anything that gets rendered to
the browser I believe is thought to be
best to be put into body again I'm not
like a super designer and stuff so I
could be wrong but I'm pretty sure
anything that gets like basically
rendered by the by the browser should
nowadays go inside the body could be
wrong whatever anyway tutorials and then
maybe we could replace some of these
things
for example maybe this would be home
kind of like it is oops not home their
home also make this linked to home as
well so we'll call this home and then
let's do a slash register and then make
this one slash login so we'll call this
register long and save that come back
over here refresh boom we have ourselves
a beautiful you can't totally see it in
all its beauty there we go we have
ourselves a beautiful navbar we are off
to the races so of course all these
things you could change like you could
add style and stuff like that into this
navbar if you wanted and change like the
background colors and same thing with
like the card all that we can change all
those colors because obviously these
colors or not these colors so I'm going
to talk at the end how we can change
thats but more SMO specifically with
materialized CSS but I'm gonna leave
that for the very very end because maybe
not everybody cares maybe not everybody
wants that they want to get back into
the Django so I'm gonna stop my focus on
that for now and really that's all the
CSS that we're gonna do for the moment
so the next thing for us to consider is
yes this is our homepage but eventually
we're gonna have like other pages okay
we're going to have like tutorial pages
we're gonna have maybe like a an about
page we're gonna have maybe a forum
where we're gonna maybe have all these
things right and on all of those pages
they're gonna be different HTML pages
but yet we need to bring in the CSS we
need to bring in the navbar so yeah okay
you know every time we could like copy
and paste the HTML file and then change
the contents within not the end of the
world but also pretty challenging when
the time comes and it will that you
decide you want to change the navbar
then you gotta change it on all your
files okay so it gets kind of messy
pretty quickly so that's not the way we
want to do it instead what we want to
use is two things that come from our
come with Django
in the templating that we get and that
is extends and include so the first
thing I think we're gonna do is actually
extends and so the way that I'm gonna do
that is first we're so we got home dot
HTML that's gonna stay the same but
we're actually gonna make a copy I wish
I could copy but I can't that way so I'm
going to go into my site main templates
main home I'm actually going to copy
paste I'm gonna call this now header so
that's hetero HTML let's go ahead and
open up hetero HTML and header will be
the thing that encases everything so you
might actually see this called like main
or something like that the term header
probably actually shouldn't even I don't
know your header is the one I should use
but I'm not gonna worry about that this
is just gonna be the type of file that
encompasses everything and header will
actually include the footer which we
don't have yet but if you did have one
that's probably where it would go anyway
this is the thing that's going to
encapsulate all the other things and
really all the other things are probably
gonna sit within body but even something
like nav no reason why that would be the
case but probably this stuff right this
is the only thing that's unique truly
unique to the homepage so because of
that in the header what I want to do is
take the stuff that is truly unique to
the homepage and delete it I know it's
very sad but instead what we're gonna
replace that with now is block content
oh my goodness and then we will end
block and again I'm not sure if you can
actually have a space there we should
test it I should find out the answer
anyways now anything that extends this
header file is actually just gonna it's
just it's going to know okay I populate
into there now I know some people will
be thinking well what if you had like
two things like what if you wanted to
have something here and then something
here that's what you would use include
for which we will talk about soon so
what I'd like to do now is finish with
home dot HTML so inside of our home dot
HTML what we need to do is basically
this is going to say who I should have
deleted all that okay do this come over
here this and then I'm gonna move these
around here very good very good
okay so then all you need to say is
you're basically going to tell Django
that this is going to extend some
specific template so in this case we
extend and then again this is so you
start in the templates directory so its
main salaah header dot HTML HTML great
block content block content save and
we've done a lot of things so let me see
how we did hopefully we didn't screw
anything up okay great everything looks
the same so it sounds like we we did it
so now our header file is on its own and
then every like unique page that we
write we just say hey the extends here's
the actual content and that content is
just gonna sit right here so it's a nice
convenient way to for us to to keep
things kind of clean and then also not
continue repeating ourselves ok so I
think I'm gonna say we're all set at
that point we'll worry about the navbar
later where we include it but the navbar
is gonna change
not super significantly but it's gonna
change as we actually use these buttons
and need to change them and stuff
anyways right now I'm not really too
worried about it so I'll leave that and
the other thing I want to talk about is
changing
changing the actual design here so what
I'm going to do is we'll come over to
materialise CSS and if you want to
customize this go ahead and code that
main site hit get started maybe there we
go I did click it and what we want is
this sass so go ahead and click on that
source and then while you're waiting on
that we're gonna go ahead and grab koala
sass probably you need something that's
gonna compile the sass so I'll grab that
hopefully it doesn't take us too long to
install it I seem to have recollection
that one time this took a while but I'll
at least talk you guys through it and
then I'll also be hosting at least the
sass file but then also I could probably
host the materialize that CSS file as
well but I want you guys to understand
like how it's done so in the old days
you would have to go through and like
you know find and replace which is not
ideal so instead what you can do is sass
is you just modify a couple of variables
instead and or in this case quite a few
variables and but it's a lot easier than
finding and replacing and then there's
like certain ones that you happen to
miss and you're like ah shucks and that
that's exactly what you say it shucks so
while that's installing that does look
like it's gonna take a while please go
faster okay so let me extract all here
okay cool so this is from misty realized
so if I go to source
if I go to source I'll come into here
basically once koalas were little gold
you'll come into sass actually probably
preloads the actual sass file that you
need but in this but what you need to do
first is come into sass directory let me
just scroll in here and then probably
components and then we're looking for
color color variables so we will open
that with sublime text great this is
what contains all of the variables this
is
quite a few variables as we can see but
the big thing to take away is that you
like the CSS is like you know probably
10,000 or 100,000 lines okay so you
definitely don't want to mess with that
if you don't have to so what you would
do is like this is the primary color so
materialize red this is the base color
and then these are like go I want to say
this is dark lighter lighter lighter
lighter and then this is like dark and
one that's good start green darker I
can't remember but you can go to like a
color picker for example so like HTML
HTML hex color something like that I'm
sure we can find one let's go to this
first one right here fabulous so we
click on maybe this here maybe I thought
I could do that
why can't oh it's right below okay
anyway yeah so come in here let's just
copy this color paste that in boom okay
so this is the default materialised red
color also I'm just curious does it get
lighter or darker as we go down these
numbers so that wolf it's got to get
darker right it's gotta get darker sure
enough okay so instead like we could
change it to be like for Python
programming net maybe the default is
more alike
I don't know we'll go with this blue
like a these aren't the exact ones but
so you go with that as the base you come
over here you say okay lighten will go
with this is like super freaking light
loop and then you could kind of keep
going down the line here I don't know
which one is the navbar one of these
things is the actual navbar so I kind of
need to replace probably all of them
unfortunately there's there's got to be
like a better way to get like a list of
colors somebody somebody will comment
below and be like hey hey man
here's how you do it alright darker and
I want to say these good you know slowly
darker I'm just trying to show this as
an example anyways
really matter if I'm totally incorrect
like I said I will host mine okay so
paste that save alright so now the next
thing let's just assume we're gonna use
materialized red now you could go and
change all of these like so materialize
is gonna use various colors for
different things one of the more popular
ones that it's gonna use is like the
yellow and stuff like that so you may
want to come in
modify the yellow a lot of buttons are
gonna default to yellow also they use
like a cyan color frequently I want to
say that would be literally cyan
probably anyway it could also be teal I
don't really know cyan verse teal
comment below what the difference is
maybe like brighter and more green
anyways so then what you can do is you
can come down here like let's say you
don't feel like editing all these
freaking colors mmm hey just want
everything to be like 2 colors well this
is all you would need to do so take this
like if you didn't want any other red
ever boom done you want blue replaced
obviously should be we replace
materialise right with blue also you
could change the name of the variable
because obviously this is blue now but
you wouldn't want to change this one cuz
this is what's gonna be referenced in
the actual CSS Hey look at that I talked
us through the installation good to go
okay so um uh-huh
I kinda want to just like I want to
replace them all and just see what it
looks like cuz hopefully we can I just
want to prove that we changed the color
of the bar surely surely that's good
enough okay so now so we come into here
it says you can drag and drop
historically on Windows I've had a
problem with this on Mac it works fine
let's see what happens so I come into
here Bota Boop
nope what if I go back to this one nope
nope what if I go this one no okay so
instead I'll click this plus up here we
will go into downloads materialise
that should be enough done okay in this
first file it kind of I guess it just
automatically detects which which file
and the entire tree is acceptable so
it's this one so you click on that and
then you hit compile we wait for it
success it says CSS boom here is our CSS
so now to use it we would just go into
main we don't even have a static yet
okay
well same principle applies I thought
this would be so much quicker me static
main again sadly honestly probably CSS
and then drag that in OOP billon great
now we just need to call upon it so we
would come into header h2 ml and
honestly we could probably take that
paste okay so it won't so it'll be
simply static and then it was main and
then we actually already did the CSS
directory yeah we were smart right and
then where is my okay and then
materialized dot CSS save drum roll
everybody dang it
404 not found my static main CSS I don't
think we would have to reload the web
page but let me just like maybe I don't
think that's gonna be the problem
oh that was the problem okay so I'm I
guess when you first load the I can't
get over that that actually was it
anyway I guess when you first load the
page or when you first run your site it
probably that's when it figures out
where all your directories are so it
gets the directory tree in the file tree
and but how do they tell
plates work so you're telling me the
templates I can add that dynamically but
not the static I'm not sure that makes
any sense but apparently I'm guessing
that's something to do with it
anyway this video is about five hours
long quick shout out to my most recent
sponsor is Daniel Aguiar I recognize
that name Yuri sponsored or remembered
Jackson Warren Hubert Sergey Sergey and
then Hannes Kalama I recognize that name
too a couple a couple people cancelled
and read up you just couldn't live
without it thank you guys very much for
your support and I think we're all set
in this tutorial in the next tutorial we
are going to be running away at a high
rate of speed from design because I'm
not a designer and instead we're gonna
go back into pure Django and we're going
to be focusing on user accounts because
we want to be able to actually log in
users and later do and actually I start
with register that's a step 1 register
users then log in users log out users
all that fun stuff
so anyways questions comments concerns
suggestions whatever feel free to leave
them below if you want to support the
content you can do it by clicking that
beautiful blue button anyways see you
guys next time